hello again in this lecture we are going
to discuss the Poisson distribution and
its main characteristics for starters we
denote a Poisson distribution with the
letters P o and a single value parameter
lambda we read the statement below as
variable Y follows a Poisson
distribution with lambda equal to 4 okay
the Poisson distribution deals with the
frequency with which an event occurs
within a specific interval instead of
the probability of an event the Poisson
distribution requires knowing how often
it occurs for a specific period of time
or distance for example a Firefly might
light up three times in 10 seconds on
average we should use a Poisson
distribution if we want to determine the
likelihood of it lighting up eight times
in 20 seconds the graph of the Poisson
distribution plots the number of
instances the event occurs in a standard
interval of time and the probability for
each one thus our graph would always
start from 0 since no event can happen a
negative amount of times however there
is no cap to the amount of times it
could occur over the time interval ok
let us explore an example imagine you
created an online course on probability
usually your students ask you around 4
questions per day but yesterday they
asked 7 surprised by this sudden spike
in interest from your students you
wonder how likely it was that they would
ask exactly 7 questions in this example
the average number of questions you
anticipate is 4 so lambda equals 4 the
time interval is one entire workday and
the singular instance you are interested
in is 7 therefore Y is 7 to answer this
question we need to explore the
probability function for this type of
distribution
alright as you already saw the Poisson
distribution is wildly different from
any other we have gone over so far it
comes without much surprise that its
probability function is far different
from anything we have examined so far
the formula looks as follows P of y
equals lambda to the power of Y times
the Euler's number to the power of
negative lambda over y factorial before
we plug in the values for our course
creation example we need to make sure
that you understand the entire formula
let's refresh your knowledge of the
various parts of the formula first the e
you see on your screen is known as
Euler's number or Napier's constant as
the second name suggests it's a fixed
value approximately equal to two point
seven two we commonly observe it in
physics mathematics in nature but for
the purpose of this example you only
need to know its value secondly a number
to the power of negative n is the same
as dividing one by that number to the
power of n in this case e to the power
of negative lambda is just one over e to
the power of lambda right going back to
our example the probability of receiving
seven questions is equal to four raised
to the seventh degree multiplied by e
raised to the negative four over 7
factorial that approximately equals
16384 times point zero one eight three
over five thousand forty or point zero
six therefore there was only a six
percent chance of receiving exactly
seven questions so far so good
knowing the probability function we can
calculate the expected value by
definition the expected value of y
equals the sum of all the products of a
distinct value in the sample space and
it's probability by plugging in we get
this complicated expression eventually
we find that the
value is simply lambda similarly by
applying the formulas we already know
the variance also ends up being equal to
lambda both the mean and the variance
being equal to lambda serve as yet
another example of the elegant
statistics these distributions possess
and why we can take advantage of them
great job everyone now if we wish to
compute the probability of an interval
of a Poisson distribution we will take
the same steps we usually do for
discrete distributions we find the joint
probability of all individual elements
within it if you found this video
interesting and want to gain an edge in
your career make sure to LIKE comment
and subscribe and don't forget to check
out some of our other videos for another
quick win in the data science skills
department